-2 x 2, cela fait...
Cela fait pas grand chose.
Je continue, tant pis.
2 x 3.
2 x 3, ça fait un peu plus.
Ouai. Ouai.
2 x 4.
Ca doit faire entre
les 6 et les 87.
Je vais vérifier
avec ma règle à calcul.
Où est-elle ?
Bon, ça fait rien.
Je pose 8, je retiens 12,
cela me donne...
-L'âge du capitaine !
-C'est quoi ?
-Bonjour, Casimir.
C'est très sérieux
ce que tu fais là.
Tu as des devoirs à faire
pour demain ?
-Non, je prépare mes cours
pour enseigner à l'école
de l'Ile aux enfants.
Comme tu peux le voir,
je vais enseigner le calcul,
la géométrie
et la pifométrie.
-La "pifomé" quoi ?
-La pifométrie.
-Je suis pas très forte
en math,
mai j'ai jamais entendu parler
de la pifométrie.
-C'est une science nouvelle
dont je suis le génial inventeur.
Je t'expliquerai. Va t'asseoir,
tu seras ma première élève.
Je pose 8,
je retiens 12,
j'obtiens...
-L'âge du capitaine !
-Qui a dit ça ?
-C'est moi, Casimir.
C'est quoi, ça ?
-Que vous arriviez en retard
est déjà assez grave,
et qu'en plus
vous semiez la perturbation,
ça devient intolérable !
-Casimir à l'air
de mauvaise humeur.
-On ne chuchote pas
pendant les cours !
Alors, prenez votre crayon,
un cahier, et asseyez-vous !
-Oui, monsieur.
-Silence ! On commence.
Je prends ma craie
et je trace
un rond.
-On dit un cercle.
-Qui a dit ça ?
-Moi.
On dit un cercle.
-François, sortez !
-C'est toujours pareil !
On dit un cercle,
et puis c'est un carré.
-Sortez !
Je vous avait pourtant prévenu !
Julie, comment s'appelle
cette figure géométrique ?
-Eh bien,
il me semble
que c'est un carré.
-Je vois ! Forte tête, hein !
Très bien ! J'aime ça !
Vous aurez zéro !
-Ca, c'est un rond.
Enfin, un cercle.
-Julie, sortez !
-Casimir, tu n'auras plus d'élève,
et tu ne sauras pas
si ton cours est au point.
-C'est vrai. Alors, rassieds-toi.
-Ne t'inquiète pas, nous appelons
François et les enfants
et ils vont t'aider.
François ! Les enfants ! Venez !
Nous allons essayer
d'aider Casimir
à trouver le nom
de certaines formes géométriques.
-Bonne idée. Regarde, Casimir.
Voilà. Alors, c'est quoi ?
-C'est une boule.
-Non, Casimir.
-C'est une sphère.
-Très bien. C'est une sphère.
-Quand je joue à la pétanque,
je joue au sphère ?
-Si tu veux.
Tu as à peu près compris.
-En tout cas,
la géométrie à côté de la
pifométrie, c'est très facile.
-La pifométrie ?
-D'après Casimir,
c'est une science nouvelle
dont il est le génial inventeur.
-Vu tes connaissances en géométrie,
je serais un peu méfiant,
quant à cette science
que tu aurais inventé.
-Mon pauvre François,
tu penses que la Terre
est encore plate,
alors qu'elle est "boulique".
-"Sphérique".
-La Terre est composée
de 2 "hémisboules".
-"Hémisphères" !
-Calmez-vous.
François, laisse-lui expliquer
sa fameuse "pifométrie".
-Comment travailler dans
une telle "atmosboule" de méfiance ?
-"Atmosphère".
-François, sois gentil.
Casimir, nous t'écoutons.
-Allez !
-La pifométrie est une science
qui permet de deviner des figures
et des volumes géométriques
les yeux fermés.
Je vais vous montrer.
Cachez-moi les yeux.
-Avec quoi ?
-Avec ça.
-Viens là, Casimir.
Tu ne vois pas ?
-Je ne vois rien.
-Parfait.
-Maintenant,
prenez ce plateau.
Je commence la démonstration.
Bien.
Ceci est un cylindre de chèvre.
Ceci est un rectangle
de pont-l'évêque.
Ne pas confondre le pont-l'évêque
avec le carré de l'est.
Ceci est un cercle
de camembert.
Ca, c'est une magnifique
boule de Hollande.
Et pour terminer,
un triangle de brie.
Voilà.
-CASIMIR.